hi there Steve coffin here I'm back from
my travels back in Vancouver and happy
to be home today I'm gonna talk about
learning styles and in particular visual
learners before that I just want to
again relay to you just how satisfying
it is to be able to speak many different
languages when I was in London I don't
think there was a single sales clerk in
any store or a restaurant waiter who was
British so I was able to communicate
with people in you know Greek Romanian
even some Arabic even some Farsi but of
course and Spanish French Italian but
Ukrainian even I got an extra Easter in
this square because I spoke to the
fellow who was shucking the oysters in
Ukrainian
but of course my Greek and my Romanian
are lacking and not a problem because I
have studied them I have the resources
the many stories that I listen to and
read so many many times they're in my
brain somewhere they're also in link I
can go review them and they'll come back
to me and I'm confident that every bit
of effort I put into those languages is
gonna come back but it sort of relates
again to to the theme and that is that
language learning is is really to my
mind as I've said many times it's
primarily about input if you with enough
input and enough comprehension and the
sufficient vocabulary you will
eventually be able to speak you don't
need to worry about what you can speak
now day one week one week ten or
whatever but that this process of
acquiring a language is one of
associating meaning with the sounds of
words and the written word to me that is
the sort of connections that have to be
made and the sort of visual strategy
which I had for example starting into
Arabic they'd have a picture of a camel
or a picture of a chicken or a picture
of an apple and relate that to a word
written in Arabic I find that that
doesn't help very much the visual
representation of what we're learning of
words is very limited for a variety of
reasons first
because there's only so much that you
can represent visually you know feelings
are much more difficult to represent
that way and second of all because
ultimately the connection the visual
connection is with a written word that's
the most useful thing because you have
to eventually be able to read and if
you're looking at a word and all you can
think of is you know dog then you're not
really reading the letters that are
there and I know I struggle with my
Arabic and not my Farsi I struggle with
getting used to the writing system it's
not a matter of theoretically knowing
what the letters represent it's actually
being able to comfortably read and I am
getting I'm slowly getting better at it
and I find that as a consequence I hear
the words more clearly when I listen so
there's a real connection between what
you hear and what you see written and in
fact there is I should point out by the
way that there is lots of research over
the last 10 years that points out that
learning styles essentially don't exist
you just have to google debunking
learning styles and you'll find ample
articles on that subject
also I'm gonna leave a link here in the
description box to an article that
explains that the part of the brain that
is used when we read is the same part of
the brain it's the same function as when
we listen to words so it's the same
you're reinforcing that same sort of
process the ability to make sense to
make derive meaning out of the written
word and the words that you hear and so
and so now I'm finding and of course
because Farsi is as a language more
similar to other European languages it's
easier than Arabic and also in Farsi the
writing system is a little more
consistent than it is in Arabic in other
words I am more likely to be able to
pronounce a Farsi word correctly than an
Arabic word because there are fewer you
know like son letters and moon letters
and other inconsistencies that we find
in Arabic don't exist in Farsi however
by doing the Farsi and reading in Farsi
it's all contributing to me being able
to read those letters better and better
as I read my Arabic I find that both of
them are sort of reinforcing the each
one is reinforcing the other but the
process is very much one of connecting
written words to spoken words that
that's the process and as I improve my
ability to do that as I hear the
language more and more clearly as I can
read more and more easily as I can more
easily derive meaning as I'm reading and
listening all of this is thus
snowballing improvement in acquiring the
language and I don't think there is
anyone who in the research suggests that
some people may prefer to watch videos
or may prefer to look at pictures but in
terms of how we learn there is no real
difference and we all have to learn to
read I shouldn't say we have to we can
learn without reading but reading is
such a powerful way to it to acquire
information in any language and a
powerful way to increase your vocabulary
and the short path to improve reading
skills is to focus on this connection
between the written word and the sound
of that word and even in languages like
I mean English is not as consistent as
Spanish so therefore it's more difficult
and Arabic is even more difficult
however if you do enough reading and
enough listening you start to associate
certain words with certain sounds it may
not always be possible in Arabic to
reproduce the sound if you haven't seen
that word before
but eventually as we read more and more
we have to get used to these words we've
seen them before and so I just wanted to
sort of make this point that that the
visual connection that I make
increasingly in a language is between
the written word and the sound of that
word and then eventually to the meaning
of that word and this goes beyond you
know red green car house door it also
goes as far
as the sort of grammatical structures
once we get used to the fact that
certain ideas are expressed a certain
way and if that expression of the idea
is grammatically correct that's then
what I cling to not some reference back
to a rule that tells me that this is
this case or this is some other rule so
just to say that when it comes to visual
learning some of you may think your
visual learners I challenge you I don't
think that's the case I think we all
have to follow more or less the same
strategies when we acquire a language so
and I you know I look forward to the
usual comments and criticisms bye for
now
[Music]